today's topic we're gonna be doing a
follow-up everyone requested that we
watch part two because we watched part
one on Jubilee where this couple
discussed things and I cringed
uncontrollably so let's watch the part
two since there's a follow-up where two
years later they end up talking and
watching the video and discussing their
feelings about it
Oh fYI we were right they didn't stay
together content hi guys I'm right now
in the Czech Republic in Prague I
approve I approve of your location
welcome visit you soon I don't know
about that but I definitely proved that
country this is no distant memory that
lives on the internet for millions to
see when she talks she always sounds
like she's just waking up I enjoyed it
yeah that's not you sound like when you
wake up you know what I know women who
do bad yeah and it's important to know
because morning time is when the real
fun happens that's actually your
testosterone levels our eyes yeah yeah
it's been a while since I've even seen
the video so with that being said I'll
cut it short let's just just go
was it a yes I mean should I really
answer him for some reason the first 10
seconds of this video is probably one of
the most commented parts of the video
people are really surprised that my
voice I went on his profile and I got
very interested and I start liking and I
start like watching his videos what he's
doing and I've been really caught with
his voice and I just messaged him and I
told him that he had an amazing voice
and we started talking like that you
know what's interesting about that kind
of German German Norwegian yeah just
that whole like Northern Europe mmm the
accent Oh everything sounds matter of
fact they just like everything they say
I just take it as like this is what's
gonna happen if they were to tell me
like so I'm going to stick this needle
in your testicles and everything just
sounds like it's not a not a sexy accent
it's not it's just an accent that kind
of demonstrates a bit of authority and
even if they sound like they're living
if you add Mr Bond to the end of their
sentence if they sound like a villain
how long ago did you watch this a very
long time ago you stopped bond accidents
are very attractive other ones that are
not and this is one of those ones that
can be depending on your disposition
what it just sounds very authoritative
yeah two months made it like something
that I will have always to carry with me
when I see this video it just brings me
back to the states that I felt a lot of
overwhelming and anxieties I'm not gonna
lie this is still super sweet like
watching that
still melts my heart especially with the
flamenco in the background so are y'all
married are you friends are you friends
of benefits like what's the relationship
this is a good question actually so we
actually had an argument and where I
stand is that I don't really know
exactly and I kind of prefer it that way
I knew that it was over I kind of liked
the smooth jazz coming in there
generally trying to paint Temasek here
comes the sugary words yeah I would
agree with ya when she said yeah he's my
boyfriend he's like I don't wanna I'm
like me was the first minute when she
was just look at it like it was a bit of
a disconnect for me that our
relationship is like the perfect
representation of like a digital
postmodern world where there are
absolutely no labels no gender and no
age or like anything to define what the
hell were experiencing in this short
amount of three months and that was the
moment that everybody watching realized
Pierre EXO is a multi-dimensional boy at
least you know bro bro yeah I'm not
gonna lie when I first heard that I had
that same suspicion you know what it is
I think it's just the fact that once you
start using all these terms to speak and
abstract because people like concrete
and the thing is boys operating the
abstract yeah they operate in this realm
of you know we're seeing each other but
I don't know where this is going to
break right so they've internalized the
experience and they associate any kind
of vague talk Amanda's as being there's
not recognizing that sometimes there's
just uncertainty for example when a
woman if I say I wanna sleep with a girl
said I'm not sure how I feel about that
I want to take some time I won't be like
yeah you know because you uncertain but
the way we internalize men being
abstract is they're being deceitful
they're using the abstractness and no
commitment to be able to get what they
want without actually having to give
anything but it's like when when people
are using too many words and say what do
you want to say
sure you can it that way I would say
it's it's important to explain stuff
I understand it's just that when people
hear too many words at some point
they're gonna be quick to fit it's a boy
it's not about using too many words it's
about what you're saying with those
words if you said to a girl a long love
letter with a thousand words and it was
she wouldn't call you boy's room it's
not about too long of an explanation
long it's about him being is it vague
and you're just trying to get out of
seeing what you want to say yeah right
being evasive I'm not mad at the job the
job was amazing I was being a little
more assertive than I needed to be
because she kept claiming something that
I really didn't want at the time here's
my boyfriend he's saying well I don't
want to label this relationship and I'm
like well he is my boyfriend
because for me it's just like I'm seeing
somebody like constantly for me it's
just like make sense I don't think she
gets it that's the weird thing after two
years I would have hoped you would have
learned the lesson that's probably the
saddest part it confirms what I was
thinking in the first video we watched
the first video I was like there's
something unhinged there's something
that she's not getting righteous from
the first video like where he was like I
don't know what he's not he's my
boyfriend there's something that is
crazy about that way of thinking that's
just confirmed to me now that she still
doesn't get that and she didn't
introspect what even if she did yeah I
would define it as just a lack of
empathy if empathy is trying to use your
own experiences to understand people and
what they're feeling she was not able to
do that and she would not take what he
wanted and that's a very large problem
with any relationship you need to be
able to understand what the other
person's coming from and to respect that
and she was just not able to do that and
on such a big note like defining a
relationship that's super important yeah
yeah I love him of course I think he's
amazing he's just otherworldly so
there's something like I thought this
would be a lot easier cuz we're reacting
to people to reacting to themselves I
felt like we were even get second-degree
cringe it wouldn't be so bad but oh man
that's so cringy even when it's a little
box I can't you know why why cuz in the
little box she's not getting in and now
she's watching herself until not getting
it and she doesn't get it
it's like not getting you twice you
please sports like a basketball game
yeah and you lost that game you like I
should have won that game and then you
watch the replay you like I sort of won
that game but the errors are clearly
there yeah I agree
I think was a yes is that a yes you know
it already you can feel it anyway yeah I
can feel it yeah so of course I love you
do you love her
damn damn daddy
damn Daniel again with the boys and you
know he's not I mean I don't know I
don't know is love I'm not gonna give
him a verdict you don't know his love
life either I don't know it either but I
thought about that situation it's like
he clearly said it to her we had an
argument about this I don't want to name
it and she clearly means it yeah
that's not being he said exactly what he
wanted being undefined she was stubborn
to define it the problem is if she was
living on one dimension and he was
living between multiple so as an intern
that she wasn't on the same page because
what if he had said that to her on a
different dimension and then he had this
interaction with her on a different
dimension well she isn't in dimension 2
she's in dimension 3 mm-hmm so she
wouldn't have recognized what he was
saying okay then multiverse I think
you're a beautiful person I think you're
extremely unique and you're also also
extremely talented if you ask somebody
do you love me and they start writing me
off all these compliments but they don't
well you know that's basically them
trying to pad it before they give you
the note well let's listen but on top of
that you believe in yourself like no
other and that's something the rest of
the world needs to learn and I think
that's one of the big purposes that you
have here to show people that you know
he probably means all this stuff you
know he probably means all this stuff
but because he's not saying what the
viewers want to hear which is do you
love her or not
they feel like she's in so what would it
be better for him to be like no I don't
love you you want to still call him he
was basically trying to say what he
values in her even if that's not
necessarily love you can still value
someone tremendously you can't win no
you can't we're in a situation you can't
win no no because you're gonna hurt
somebody you're gonna be mad a man broke
a girl's heart is always an [ __ ]
you hurt her feelings how dare I assert
myself ladies when men make approaches
on you and you say no no one's like how
dare you say no you're entitled to
enforce your form of consent and there's
nothing problematic about that no means
no in this case his you're one of the
most wonderful people was amazing
I'm gonna cry and she's crying what
actually watching this ugly Criers I'm
trying to see this listen I got a watch
though most men are ugly I think it's
what I'd never see men cry it's very
rare we how we do it in the dark lights
off Yugi we don't even want to see your
own reflection oh man girls know how to
cry cuz we stand in the marriage magna
cry some of them don't because it's
nasty looking and they still do it yeah
all right but let's try to get through
this I got many people it was very hard
it just shows you that how most people
just don't see bad couples when they're
looking at it it's like the people will
be like oh my god there's such a good
couple they're gonna last forever later
find out like the boyfriend was up you
beat her all the time and cheated on her
every day you guys have no ability to
tap into the subtleties of what a good
and a bad relationship looks like that's
why people said this stuff if you watch
this video and you saw a good couple
booboo your definition of a good
relationship is terrible you know
sometimes you see it wrong and it's
really two lines one on top of the other
one is in blue one is in red and if you
put the cargos different goggles red or
blue you're gonna see different things
right if you see the blue if you put the
blue goggles no one's gonna see the red
vice-versa
that's a bit what it is all their biases
and what people lacked in their lives
that's their goggles and the only seen
picking shoes yeah but they're together
and they're talking about I never have a
conversation am I would be like a nerd
to live sometimes and they see things
like that they're ideal which is not an
ideal it is not an ideal cuz you just
decide to not look at the signs that
this is bad you decide ignore because
the rest of them is really in line with
your ideal right that's why y'all need
to pull out some a sub-base okay and if
you defiance how do you go
love is really complicated
even before it was already over I saw
him the last time in Christmas and I've
never seen him again so we spoke to him
uh-huh
and you just rewatched the video mm-hmm
and he is willing to do a call with you
now if you are comfortable with
okay so what's new how was the filming
good it was memories
how does it feel just first off to see
each other it's weird huh phone calls
screaming on each other if exactly what
you said they don't see the abusing with
the other yeah it's exactly that you see
you don't see the signs you did not see
the sign they were clearly not on the
same page and it showed I'm sure a lot
of people didn't see that matches Wow
baffles me and I didn't want to have any
contact I actually held on to that for a
long time which is why I hadn't came
back around to talk to you
good listen someone is toxic with you
cut contact don't really connect you
should pull yourself out of that
situation
110% brazo good for him the problem that
people do is that they hold onto the
good parts ya know tolerate the really
bad yeah because they just hold onto the
really good it's like whenever you you
ate something yeah yeah but
I didn't feel hungry after the fall so
delicious yeah but you were up all night
thank you like at that time at that
moment when it was all overwhelming I
really wanted to talk to someone that
was experiencing the same thing than I I
was experiencing and that's why I was
trying to reach you out and I shouldn't
have done that and I'm sorry about this
I want to say sorry for any harm I've
done to you as well cuz you know I'm not
gonna try to say that it was the perfect
one and by all means I'm not you know so
I'm sorry for anything that I've done
that is that has hurt you or are you
here anyway awesome if you could go back
in time would you still do the video you
see about to cry if she no I think he's
about to cry yeah the moment you see the
chin start to move on a man and the
little dimples and the children show it
yeah that's it yeah this yeah yeah no
would
I would 100% do it again when the video
released it was just like all of the
reminders of the situation and the
comments were like flooding in I think
both all of both of our social media
platforms were exploding at the time I
honestly couldn't sleep for a week
because not only was the phone buzzing
every few seconds it was just like
really really overwhelming but I mean
I'm not gonna lie it actually they made
me really happy because there was a lot
of people that could relate to the story
you know yours and mine our relationship
as strong as it was was very fun and we
had a good time I think it's interesting
that what he took away from in terms of
positive is that it helped a lot of
people and where she took away for it
was like it was a great little capsule
for the both of us now again this could
be just an editing and not reflective of
their views
no cuz I've done that yeah yeah when
[ __ ] got contoured they face at least
I open up the eyes because that's
because you're trying to not to cry yeah
Suze hands up listen you're in a dark
room dark backdrop you have the right to
turn off the lights it's funny that
she's not crying anymore in years she
passed all the cry for help
yeah hey here you go I was not expecting
this it's very good actually
she needed closer and that's what she's
not crying no more that's a closer to
closer Hall wow what a beautiful little
ending she closed the laptop and walk
away as if she's walking away from this
chapter in our life yeah oh my god close
what editing yes superb Jubilee let me
say this good job great powers my
favorite x-men you know listen on a
scale of 1 to 10 in terms of a breakup
and like reconciliation I would give
this like a 7 I probably deduct a couple
points
mostly because because you didn't have
to do a video about it
no mostly because uh maybe some lessons
weren't completely learned just as it
was a couple of disconnects there that's
you know this is one thing to apologize
but not understanding what it is you're
apologizing or in which ways you were
really wrong means that you may be at
risk to repeat those mistakes and again
I'm saying this also based on editing
she may have learned in and Jubilee
didn't put it in so we don't know but I
just from what what I saw that's what I
got and I didn't give it a full 10 out
of 10 because I didn't get to see all of
his tears and that would have really
made the video much better but mine not
cry or Batman I put no makeup - no not
really I wouldn't rate this because I'm
rating a breakup that's weird
I don't rate a breakup you know what I
mean wonder you can't they rate
everything I rate you
I rate the dollar I rate this breaker
you know what might it means something
different than you allow its allow it
might allow it might use me something
different yeah anyways I wouldn't rate
it but you wouldn't say it's a fit
breakup it's not fair
that's not fair it's weird really weird
I wouldn't I won't no no I wouldn't way
it's just it's good though they're both
single G they're both single their chirp
sing other people we don't know
good point let us know what you guys
think in the comments below what did you
think of this video and their breakup
and all that good stuff and our take on
it you disagree with some of the points
we made we want to hear from y'all what
is a little other side note we got a
live stream that we're gonna be doing
weekly here on YouTube so be sure to
check our YouTube stories to know when
and on Wednesday 8 p.m. eastern time we
do an Instagram live where if you guys
want to jump in on the camera and ask us
questions from your own cell phone you
can so Instagram subscribe to the admin
preach Instagram follow it you want to
get that info and also on a Friday
nights Eastern Time at midnight we are
well it's actually from the night of
Friday to Saturday we have the release
of the podcast the preach yawns have it
before so subscribe to the pitch 1 if
you want to have this before
yep so that's pretty much it
you